so before we were talking about AI risk
ni AI safety and just trying to lay out
in a very generalized sort of way how
general artificial intelligence can be
dangerous and some of the type of
problems it could cause and just
introducing the idea of AI safety or AI
alignment theory as an area of research
in computer science and we also talked
about super intelligence and the kind of
problems that that the unique problems
that can pose and I thought what would
be good is to bring it down to a more
concrete example of current AI safety
research that's that's going on now and
kind of give a feel for where we are um
where humanity is on figuring these
problems out supposing that we do
develop a general intelligence you know
an algorithm that actually implements
general intelligence how do we safely
work on that thing and improve it
because the situation with this stamp
collector is it's from its first instant
it's of super intelligence so we create
it with a certain goal and as I said as
soon as we switch it on it's extremely
dangerous
which people pointed out and it's true
you know was a thought experiment it's
true that that's probably not what will
happen right you'll have some
significantly weaker intelligence first
that may work on improving itself or we
may improve it so the situation where
you just create the thing and then it
goes off and does its own thing either
perfectly or terribly from the beginning
is is unlikely it's more likely that the
thing will be underdeveloped so then the
question is how do you make a system
which you can teach how do you create a
system which is the general intelligence
that once things in the real world and
is trying to act in the real world
but is also amenable to being corrected
if you create it with the wrong function
with the wrong utility function and you
realize that it's doing something that
actually you don't want it to do how do
you make it so that it will allow you to
fix it how do you make an AI which
understands that it's unfinished that
understands that the utility function is
working with may not be the actual
utility function it should be working
with right so utility function is what
the AI cares about so the stamp
collecting device if utility function
was just how many stamps in a year this
is kind of like it's measurable yeah
it's what it's it's the thing that it's
trying to optimize in the world the
utility function takes in world states
as an argument and spits out a number is
broadly the idea if the world was like
this is that good or bad and the AI is
trying to steer towards world states
that values are valued highly by its
utility function you don't have to
explicitly build the AI in that way but
it will always if it's behaving
coherently
it will always behave as though it's in
accordance with some utility function
also before I talked about about
converging instrumental goals that if
you have some final goal like you know
it makes them that there are
instrumental goals which are the goals
that you that you do on the way to your
final goal right so like acquire the
capacity to do printing is like perhaps
an instrumental goal towards making
stamps but the thing is there are
certain goals which tend to pop out even
across a wide variety of different
possible terminal goals so for humans an
example of convergent instrumental goal
would be money if you want to make a lot
of stamps or you want to cure cancer or
you want to establish a moon colony
whatever it is having money is a good
idea right so even if you don't know
what somebody wants you can
reasonably predict that they're going to
value getting money because money is so
broadly useful before we talked about
this we talked about improving your own
intelligence as a convergent
instrumental goal it's another one of
those things where it doesn't really
matter what you're trying to achieve
you're probably better at achieving it
if you're smarter so that's something
you can expect a is to go for even if
even without making many assumptions
about their final goal
so another convergent instrumental goal
is preventing yourself from being
destroyed it doesn't matter what you
want to do you probably can't do it if
you're destroyed so it doesn't matter
what the AI wants you can unless it
wants to be destroyed in some like
trivial case but if you di want
something in the real world and believes
that it's in a position to get that
thing it wants to be alive not because
it wants to be alive
fundamentally it's not a survival
instinct or an urge to live or anything
like that it's good for knowing good
leads in it unable to complete it it's
beauty would it be almost yes unable to
achieve its goals if it's destroyed and
it wants to achieve its goal so that's
an instrumental value it's preventing
being turned off and I'm guessing here
where we say wants to it's not like
English even want it's just a turn of
phrase yeah I mean as much as anything
it's closer actually you know I'm not
even sure I would agree like if you talk
about most machines you talk about that
they want to whatever and it's not that
meaningful because they're not agents
then our general intelligences whereas
the general intelligence when it wants
something it wants it in a similar way
to the way that people want things so
it's such a tight analogy that it
wouldn't even I think it's totally
reasonable to say that an AGI wants
something there's another slightly more
subtle version which is closely related
to not wanting to be turned off or
destroyed which is not wanting to be
changed so if you imagine let's say I
mean you have kids right suppose I were
to offer you a pill or something you
could take and this pill will like
completely rewire your brain
that you would just absolutely love to
like kill wickets right whereas right
now what you want is like very
complicated and quite difficult to
achieve and it's hard work for you and
you're probably never going to be done
you're never going to be truly happy
right in life nobody is you can't
achieve everything you want I said this
case it just changes what you want what
you want is to go eat it and if you do
that you will be just perfectly happy
and satisfied with life right okay you
want to take this pill no don't you have
a happy though yeah I want to do it
because but that's quite a complicated
specific case because it directly
opposes what I currently want
it's about your fundamental values okay
right and so not only will you not take
that pill you will probably fight pretty
hard to avoid having that pill
administer to you yes because it doesn't
matter how that future version of you
would feel you know that right now you
love your kids and you're not going to
take any action right now which leads to
them coming to heart so it's the same
thing if you have an AI this for example
value stamps values collecting stamps
and you go oh wait hang on a second I
didn't quite do that right let me just
go in and change this so that you don't
like stamps quite so much it's going to
say but the only important thing is
stamp if you change me I'm not going to
collect as many stamps which is
something I don't want there's a general
tendency for AGI to try and prevent you
from modifying it once it's running I
can understand now in the context you
put that right because it's that's it in
almost any situation being given a new
utility function is going to write very
low on your current utility function
okay so that's a problem
you want if you want to build something
that you can teach that means you want
to be able to change its each LC
function and you don't want it to fight
you
want is 100 yeah so this has been
formalized as this property that we want
early AGI to have called courage ability
that is to say it's open to be corrected